[Musique]
La violence de 1995 dont le but premier
était
[La musique]
est un langage militarisé très froid et
bureaucratique
il n'y a vraiment aucune touche personnelle
dans ce cahier c'est
toujours euh le reflet des
autres
euh de son point de vue plutôt que le
sien  réflexions
sur la façon de gérer ce qu'il faut faire et
cetera et cetera
je redessine chaque lettre
chaque phrase page par page les 400
pages
de plus en tant qu'invité performatif ou
acte performatif d'
essayer de gérer ce
matériel très dur du passé pour avoir
commis ces crimes
la chambre condamne
[Musique]
à la réclusion à perpétuité
presque
[Musique]
étranger
vous